samantha is not gone the actress that
played the role is no longer playing
that role but people aren't absent from
your life when you don't want them to be
sarah jessica parker addresses carrie
and samantha's falling out on hbo max's
sex and the city revival series and just
like that i think what's wonderful is
that we have a writer and actors who
love that character and we're really
lucky we have those memories and that
experience just a little refresher kim
cattrall who played samantha in the
original series decided not to reprise
her role it's a topic et asked the
actress about back in 2014 four years
after the release of sex and the city 2.
the most important thing is always do we
have something left to say it's about
the story if there's something more to
say yes financially it would be
fantastic for all of us uh
but
i'm really about content and uh what is
it what is it where is it going to take
me fast forward to 2021 and just like
that premieres and kim's character's
absence was addressed in episode one
carrie didn't need samantha to be her
publicist anymore things got awkward
over it and just like that sam packed up
and moved to london i always thought the
four of us would be friends forever but
sam did kinda sorta make a few
appearances throughout the first season
via text exchanges with carrie and on
monday sjp stopped by watch what happens
live with andy cohen and opened up about
those subtle moments a creative choice
she says was made by showrunner michael
patrick king he you know threaded it
through with grace and dignity and
respect yes you know and love and
affection for that character and i
thought it it it mimicked many
friendships that yeah you know
challenge each other and struggle and
want to remain connected in a way
because it's too painful and all that
echoes what michael patrick and the cast
told et at the show's premiere we knew
kim wasn't going to do the series
because she had for her reasons finished
playing samantha so then it was the
beginning point rather than ignore it we
decided to make it part of the story and
we did everything we could to honor
samantha who we love the character and
we know the fans love
no one could be another samantha i
personally feel very pleased with how
we've handled it yeah i think michael
patrick
uh cares deeply about handling it with
respect and i feel that that we have i
think that kim has made it really clear
that she's done and we've heard her and
uh
but i think that we deal with it really
well i think and really really
creatively something else they heard
outrage over carrie's husband biggs
sudden death i love that people are
upset it means they care and outrage
over how long it took carrie to call
9-1-1
and just like that
they died sarah jessica addressed all
that too it's suspended animation it's
this moment where
everything stops let's we can walk
through this together shall we yes so in
my head
she you know
struggled through this moment and tried
to get him to be responsive right and
then she you know came to her senses and
called i'm gonna say after about
two to three seconds okay yes
yes you know what i mean yes and then of
course she called 9-1-1 and got all the
help she needed from professionals so
what's next will fans get a season two
sjp didn't say but when et caught up
with cynthia nixon last month she teased
this it's not my job to figure it out
you know thank god but in terms of the
the amazing writers that we have
dreaming things up
they know much better than
[Music]